if it's in a word or it's in a look you
can't get rid of the Baba duck this
essentially gives birth to the Baba duck
the Baba duck metaphorically grows
inside her the longer she tries to deny
her trauma but after years of doing this
it grows too large for her to keep in
and even Samuel takes note of it in both
monster and the babadook Samuel becomes
obsessed with killing the monster with
the former inventing homemade
Contraptions do fight back against it
like a dart gun and a catapult backpack
both versions are obsessed with
protecting their mother from the threat
it's interesting how the absence of a
parent causes Sam to want to take on
this man of the house kind of role the
short film version of the monster is
similar in appearance to the babadook
with one key difference the babadook
wears a top hat in a cape much like
thirston the great magician who Samuel
sees as an idol Sam is an aspiring
magician himself often dressing up like
his hero perhaps the closest thing that
the boy has to a father figure in his
life it's likely no mistake that the
babadook takes on a similar form since
Amelia's grief is centered around the
loss of a man in the house a DVD of an
Illusionist is no proper replacement for
a dad